[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
okay
a little too big
just a little bit
oh
been having like issues with like
focusing on my camera here lately
hopefully you guys can hear me fine
it's only so much in my room you guys
can see right now
had the uh
the girlfriend in the
her daughter was over here and yeah
three-year-olds cannot be kind of
chaotic I ain't got I ain't got around
to cleaning yet but
it's mainly this way yeah
it's fine
I'll get to it after the Stream
we starting a colossal protocol
obviously
ah oh God
I wonder how the sound design is for
this game
I wonder how that's is
why isn't the audio working for the
capture card
according to my calculations they're not
it's you can't hear the game
play
and there ain't enough people in the
chat to tell me if you can hear it yet
oh my gosh technical issues man
technical issues
I mean why isn't the capture card
working the way it's supposed to
there we go
I got it fixed
it happened I got it fixed
I got two cameras I'm trying to debate
if I should keep the second camera
probably not
let's get rid of the second camera
probably not healthy for you guys to see
is that another camera
there is totally another camera where is
the oh
I can delete this what's up Christopher
Jones
what is this
terms of service I always
I always find it weird when you have a
terms of service
to me it feels like they're trying to
get away with some slimy stuff
oh my gosh man
I wonder if people actually read that
so they don't have a new game they call
it new experience
we got a new experience guys
I love how they give me the option after
a tutorial before the game actually
starts
that's unique
what's up Don
oh minimum security medium security
maximum Escape we're doing medium
why does King need to give him my knees
explain yourself
or why did I need to give King my knees
what's up Soma King
yeah I've never played it
King already gave me the knees for
Ragnarok
what's up childish
let me close out some of these programs
I like to turn off the
turn off the
the sound I mean turn off the light but
I feel like I I feel like you guys won't
be able to see me very well if I turn
off the light
who is that
Xbox
oh we found I don't know who it is but
we found them
hold up guys let me turn off the light
and turn on the light above me
foreign
Callisto is like an actual place
six months
oh
so that's the character
when the cargo
I would say the game looks nice
make sure I'm on performance mode
where is
graphics
no we're turning that off
is there no option for performance mode
really
there's no option for performance mode
wow
I don't even know what I'm looking at
there's no game sound
hold up
it says it's on my end
um
hold up
they always be changing stuff man
oh
okay all right you should be able to
hear it now hopefully
oh my God
let's reset it
hopefully that'll fix it
yeah I don't know I don't know I'm
resetting the Xbox
all right now I saw
I think it's working now
is it working okay
I think we're good I think we're good
chat
all right
see quick resume that's why I like a
little bit about quick resume man went
straight back to where I was I got to
give the props to Quick resume in some
scenarios most of the time I'm not
really feeling quick resume but I will
say it worked good for this man
yeah
all right you guys should be able to
hear it now
why is it
I'm turning it up
on OBS and down
it's turning up in my headset
hold up
let me make sure that
okay what's what's going on why
is my headset
reading
it's like the weirdest thing I've ever
seen man
had set a sign okay
now let's try this
okay I I hear it loud on mine now tell
me how it sounds on your guys
so that's vaulting
silent
why is it registering
on here
it's like the weirdest thing I've ever
seen
let's reset again let's reset again
it might be because I did the audio
thing I don't know OBS is being weird
let's reset again guys
foreign
how does this sound now
all right let's see if it works when uh
all right does it still work
does it still work
all right we got some yeses
all right all right we good we good we
good I think
all right let's try this again
what's this game about I don't know yet
Grill I don't know yet
paying for the audio appreciate the uh
the support Sam McCain you have no idea
how much that goes right now you have no
idea
the game looks nice
son of
I had to check the other side
I don't like how there's like no butts
that you push to open these doors
they're like automatic
I don't know
tension with that music they're trying
to do
I don't think it's working well for them
oh they got in pretty easy
your ass back up here
return to the cockpit
what's going on bone what is that
oh the Chevy and no I did enough of this
in God of War
they are doing a good job so far
building up tension I don't know who
these people are we're running though
we're running
oh they see me get in there shut the
door
oh
crap
oh snap
just press up
Jacob get up here
keep going up
I feel like this fire would have caught
you on fire by now
shut that door
shut the door
I want to know how that that chick is
that his survived
the emergency clearance
back
so I am getting a little bit of like
unchartered Dead Space Vibes right now
you know what some of the set pieces
yeah girl that's
someone someone Google
how strong you have to be to withstand
a a vacuum a space vacuum
probably like ridiculously strong
it's probably not like probable that you
could do that it is a video game though
so we have to keep we have to be fair a
little bit
hey
whoa oh Max it's dead
it's fine man we put some Neosporin on
that he's good
put some Neosporin man I'm sure give him
some Tylenol he'll be fine
take a couple shots of vodka
rub some dirt on it that's right
thank you
One Life sign detected shout out to uh
Necromancer with five dollar ship I love
the beginning of this game that's why I
like to give you guys a little bit of
time to play before I play
so you guys could do the first couple
hours before me
because I don't really I want you guys
to enjoy the gameplay more than I care
about like the beginning
clicks because without you guys like the
community and like the chat what's the
point in doing this
oh your chance cargo Jackie you do your
job you let me do mine all right
sir
yes sir
what's going on
whatever you say grab him too
hey I didn't do anything
well obviously
they fell away about you
you don't got to do everything man
pretty good intro
it's a good intro I'll give them that
um it does
feel
so far it feels like really
what's what I'm looking for
set piece Vibes which obviously is the
beginning of the game
[ __ ]
okay uh inmates do not speak unless they
are spoken to it that's been a mistake
my name is Jacob Lee I'm not an
interview you were inmate
532-521 you address me is Captain Ferris
[Applause]
she crashed my ship and she killed my
first officer I don't care warden's oars
oh speak of the devil
choice
every choice in your life what's up fun
speculation
to this moment
he's being real extra right now
welcome to Black Iron prison
I just love that last part welcome
to Black Island prison
here we we serve dirt
and we get we we give you expired buns
so you know you guys how you know the
biscuits
you know they call Callisto the dead
Moon shout out to Salma King with the
two Super Chat watch reviews hopefully
it'll come to Game Pass
oh we'll see man we'll see I'm gonna
review it I still owe you guys my
Pokemon review it's time okay I'll I'll
let you guys hear the cutscene and then
we'll talk to a New Kingdom
so whatever it is you're holding on to
right there that's your old life you
gotta let that go because your new life
is entirely
rise in time
let's go
feels like a prison Riddick would break
out of
intake gate 150.
oh they into some kinky stuff man what's
going on here
Xbox fun Xbox
there you go
inmate five three two dash five two one
Dr Caitlin Marler an astrological 412 of
the ujc penal code you will now be
fitted with a core device
just prep the device
yo he's not in the system give it to him
anyway
[Applause]
oh what is that
I look like it stung a little bit
you know what they gave him they gave
him Mountain Dew
that's what they injected to them some
Mountain Dew man
they give Mountain Dew and Red Bull
combined
that's what that's what that fluid is
Mountain Dew and Red Bull combined
okay
I love how he's got like this jacket
back
block 12 sell one they could get lights
out at 1700 with 1700.
um
20
is 8 P.M
5 p.m is lights out
it's a little a little ridiculous
man you could at least play some like
some
something on there it looks like a
monitor of some sort
I'm at least like let us watch The
Golden Girls or something like
I I understand it's got to be prison
I mean I wouldn't want to watch The
Golden Girls it'd be better than
watching this though
how do I open it oh
uh when does that come out high in life
I could probably get a review code for
that to be honest it probably wouldn't
be that long oh
I told you he'd be okay
I told you guys that that man's would be
okay
give that dude some some neosporins some
Band-Aids a couple Tylenol he'd be fine
you think
this game does look really nice I gotta
give them that
oh snap
yo okay
one more
hey you guys um
you know the thing everyone's been doing
that app that gives you
like does editing on pictures
shout out to God's hit man with the two
dollar super Doritos has a one month
game pass code that Stacks oh I could
buy a bunch of Doritos
so hold up hold up babe since you're in
the chat uh they they have this this app
right now that lets you like post
pictures and it gives you like
what it will do is it'll like do like
crazy editing all right it would do like
crazy editing look what one of them did
to me
look at that guys isn't that a sexy base
look how great my beard looks
sexy bass man
oh here's another one I look like
Randolph Thor
ough systems
oh
yo yo
it's called um
it's called Luna's son or something like
that
look at that one man look at that one
guys
guess that would look like if I was buff
if I was if I had it going on man
these robots clearly ain't that
ain't nothing
you look like you've been through
something man
you look like you've been through
something
look like you've been through something
fam
all right what's going on
oh
clearly some audio issues going on
that bridge you can open myself from
there
Jacob
to save your life
so we gotta shiv
what are we gonna do with the shiv man
what are we going to do with the ship
chat
breaking out already
I feel like I feel like this isn't for
me man
someone else is breaking
something else has happened I'm not
breaking out I'm taking advantage of it
girl I'm taking advantage of it
huh
all right what's going on
[Music]
moving on down moving on there
I like the uh
the background I feel like maybe they
don't want to show you what's actually
killing people let me put on Do Not
Disturb so these things don't keep
popping up
foreign
let's go
so it's locked but we're going to use
the shiv
so far so good Spencer
I'm gonna go get some Doritos
buy like a by like
eight years of Doritos
all right
oh I like the the tutorial it's nice
oh
about a swing
we don't met we're gonna hit him again
hit him again
hit him again I'm getting demonetized
like crazy on YouTube right now look at
all this Gore this is the gore that
should have been in God of War
I'm scared to plug uh
oh what is this thing
ah
what you doing let's go buddy oh you
hitting me all right let's go let's go
oh oh
ah
come on come on let's do it again oh
let's do it again come on man what's
going on
you're taking forever
oh you got one arm
you got one r
ude I died I was playing too much man I
was playing too much I was playing way
too much
oh let's just hope that'll mess up like
everything
all right let's do this again
we won't get them this time chat they
ain't doing what they did to us a minute
ago
open up that door
okay
oh oh
we don't play in this house
we ain't stopping should have thought
about that before you tried to hit me
with a bat
[Applause]
this thing is huge
this thing ain't messing around
oh
let's go
oh
myself
oh
I could have did that better
I could have handled that a little
better I feel like I still lost a lot of
Health there I could have handled that
better
did we open all the cells up
is that what we did
we open up all the cells
no we didn't
dodgy melee to hold the left stick or
right stick before the end rejoice
did shift to hold the lipstick the other
directions
okay
now my thing is like hardcore
having like a lot of issues with my
camera here lately I might have to like
reprogram it
and what is this
all right maybe that would be a little
bit better I don't like how it's like
constantly refocusing
I'm gonna work on it sometime this week
guys
we got like some form of hammer though
this guy's not good back there I just
saw something it attacked me and it
didn't seem human
you want about it I know what I saw look
this place you're messing with your head
this is our chance whatever it was you
saw it's all the more reason to get out
here see that Watchtower
yeah that's our first stop we be there
ow elevators that way take it up to the
next level I'll be in touch
all right let's go
I feel comfortable man
got this hammer
I feel comfortable
what's up
oh
man I feel like it's not responsive
wow
oh my God what is going on with this
camera
am I using it too much or something
it's just
it's like catching up on everything that
is not supposed to
oh my God
[Music]
let me
I don't think I don't know why the
autofocus would be on the camera
it's fun this auto focus thing
clearly something's been changed
Focus
let's just do an auto focus
for right now
ah it's fine
all right
all right as long as I stay right here I
should be fine
all right let's try this again
hit him
how many hits is he taking
stop a corpse
okay we're gonna be stomping a lot
so that's locked
I don't know yet
why am I always the one in these games
doing stuff
all right let's do this
let's get killed again because the
combat system seems like it misses a
little bit now let's get him before he
gets up
can you fall
thank you
I assume this is a first aid kit
can I use it now
press okay
press down on the d-pad
That's That Mountain Dew and Red Bull
mix I do like how it is taking a little
bit to use the actual health
some pardon me don't like how people
just
oh
how you could use Health in a lot of
games like really fast I like those like
a little balance
Elias something's wrong with the
elevator I'm heading down not up
yeah he's pretty much just walking he's
not running I'll agree with you on that
move through solitary
we're in the solitary confinement chat
oh
I heard someone someone called my name
oh you look hurt
foreign
are you alive
how'd they get in there to you
I feel like there's something up there
energy converter is there a tutorial for
it
valuable contrabandons could be sold for
credits okay that gets sold for credits
tread lightly
I want like an a new weapon already
yeah Riddick I think Riddick would be a
good formula if they would actually put
money behind it
the problem with a lot of these games
they don't want to put money behind
stuff
shut the door
shot it
I told you
oh these things
let's make sure you're dead
wow
there's no
the games acting like that thing doesn't
even exist like you brush up against it
it doesn't move it doesn't like destroy
itself when you stomp on it like little
details like that matter it really helps
put your game up
there's clearly something at the end of
this
we're gonna open this door though
what's going on
man what's going on guys appreciate you
guys for coming on in man
you hurt
what's up will
I agree with you uh
Spencer I do think that this game might
be getting attacked a little bit too
much because it's not dead space but
that it
people expected a dead space type of
experience playing it so I think that's
that's why it's a little bit fair but at
the same time it's not fair because it
is a new game it's a new IP
you shouldn't judge it entirely off of
another game
good place to Gear Up
jury units
oh so that means the robots coming after
us
[Music]
has been authorized yeah oh
oh
area secured moving to Medical sector
oh let's not go to the medical sector
I feel like we can avoid the medical
sector
oh we don't
I don't want to deal with them either
dude
boys
climb up into the vents
is there another event
you know what guys
I'm feeling spicy I think I could take
this thing iron security unit active nah
I can take it I can take it oh I got you
no I can't I can't take him oh I don't
need that leg get up man get up you
don't need that leg he gonna stalk me he
gonna stop me okay maybe I can't take
the robot
yeah that robot he hit me one time my
leg just flew it just flew
information
let me record some gameplay
I'm probably gonna need it
if the program wants to load
come on man
are you gonna load
all right there we go
I have another
yeah oh God
see I I was so into to getting my
program I forgot there's a robot that's
trying to kill me
that robot didn't want nothing to do
with me
that robot got me
this robot's not gonna get me again
I do feel like that gun that
that fire
was a little bit underwhelming
I feel like the there should have been
holes in me and stuff
what's up robot
just just don't mind me
you've already
you've already messed me up a couple
times
yeah he sees you it's a rat
it is a rap if he sees you
there's no coming back from robot hands
man you think you can give hands that
robot can do it better
how'd that robot not hear that
all systems nominal how's he not hearing
this
cut it
it's a little weird the robot's not
hearing this
it's like advanced technology but he's
not hearing that much noise beside them
off
lethal fourth authorized
oh
and you've been I think you've seen
better days buddy
what's going on over there
yeah we're not robots over there let's
go over here
uh
look at all the blood
I bet you I could pick up that foot and
hurt him I bet you I could win that
fight if they let me pick up this this
foot as a weapon
oh what is that
it's a leech
they're not telling us something man
that was creepy
got some health though
I don't know if that was worth it
see what this is
take the good fuse to power doors
okay
press right to open up inventory press
Rod bumper to select the data okay so we
they kind of got like a dead space thing
going on with the
no we don't need that
right bumper
they should play this automatically I
shouldn't have to go here
[Music]
the opportunity
the opportunity
we got some opportunity guys
oh we got some opportunity
some opportunity
[Music]
okay so we need
I wish I had like a light there's got to
be a light you get in this game
somewhere
all right so here's
I have a feeling there's gonna be a lot
of this going on
just not a big fan man just not a big
fan
oh we got fire fire walkers
[Music]
they take too much damage
get that Mountain Dew
I don't got no more
I think they take too much damage
and I feel like sometimes the melee
button's a little clunky like it doesn't
actually Dodge like the Dodge button
s
necessary
you always got these Psychopaths I think
they're doing the world of favor and
they're really just crazy
I feel you
made it through this memory I'm still
looking for that weather's lock covered
this game does have a lot of dead space
aspects
oh
yeah let's just go back
oh my God
I don't look forward to doing the melee
combat I just don't
oh no I'm not here
I'm not here
I'm trying to get rid of one of them
but he's taking like 80 hits
what the hell
where's he gonna come down at
no take that out
some kind of security room
oh
you got a stun gun
all that's left is just baton
oh he's pretty messed up
you think I'd get as many of those as I
can get
all right now now we got something we
got a stun gun
well it's starting baton
yeah see you there
return to the Watchtower
do they want me to go back
do I go back
I guess I do
I guess we just went there to try to get
weapons
oh
games got really good immersion guys it
really does
I think I came through here
oh
that was ridiculous
there is no need to kill me like that
so I can't go in that way
I guess we gotta backtrack no hold up
did I just unlock it yeah dude
let's see what happens chat something
hit me
oh my God
I don't feel like I'm doing any more
damage
what the hell man
I'm not liking the melee in this game
I'm just not I feel like it's too
inconsistent I'm missing a lot of the
shot of the dodging systems it's just
it's frustrating you know I'm gonna give
it a little bit of time to open up
probably give it another hour
uh but I'm just I'm not feeling it so
far
I'm feeling the world that they've built
I want to be honest with that I am
filling the world they built
it's just as far as that I don't know
I don't know man
no but see The Last of Us
I don't know I feel like that's not a
fair comparison
oh it's not time
foreign
they acted like it was timed
it's weird to put a a Dodge system on on
the left and along
yeah we're gonna need this
there we go all right let's try to hold
it this time
I'd rather put the analog sticks
all right come on come over here
okay so you do hold it
I'm still not feeling the fact that he
takes so many hits like I like it when
you hit someone you feel like you're
actually hitting them but after about
three or four hits I'm done with the
hitting thing and it feels like they're
not done with it though like they want
me to hit him for like an hour and a
half
I don't I'm not feeling that I'm gonna
be real with the chat I'm not feeling
that
I don't need the auto Dodge thing
it's not that it's too easy I think
maybe you know and then they like sneak
out on you too so
I hit him three times there
that was three
let's get this
okay so at least you're gonna hit me
could have did a lot more damage to me
wow
I'm not feeling the dodging in this game
I feel like it's
the dodging would be good if like you
hit him two or three times it kills him
but
I don't know I don't know
I feel like there's too much
there's too much dodging going on
so let's see how many times I have to
hit this dude here let's count them
let's get them over here
so one
two three
four
all right so you there's four
uh I don't even know where he came from
get off of me
one two
I hit him five times
I like to kill animations they are
pretty lit you know he he he he eye
gouge my ass
he really went from the mice I like that
that that's unique
I'm just not enjoying
I'm just not enjoying like I feel like
I'm spending most the game just trying
to stay alive and I'm not enjoying the
combat
and they kind of put like these melee
features in the game they this the
stealth features in the game and I don't
I don't feel like the stealth is is
there enough to actually like really
enjoy the stealth to that degree
and then there's like no
melee record really
all right so that's where he came from
[Music]
someone behind me
yeah nothing I could do there man
I think I hear another person
I hit him like five times
when we were over with you guys I'm not
feeling it I'm just
I know
I know there's a lot of like
what's what I'm looking for
it's a lot of timing in this game
but I feel like games like this
generally give you multiple options of
taking about like how you want to
go a unique situation
and I feel like this game is just like
you're gonna take this stun baton and
you're gonna hit this dude over and over
again
and you're gonna hope that you can get
to them before another one comes up on
you
foreign
I hit him twice
come on
come on man I hit you like nine times
come on over here
come on buddy
come on buddy old pal
five what grass how many times I hit
almost five times it felt more more than
I'll be rude you felt like I hit him
forever
what is that light who's moving that
light
I see I think I got it
I gotta let them swing a couple times
because I feel like there's too many
like cancel animations
how the [ __ ] did you get in here
okay I got time for this [ __ ]
apparently he's used that thing on your
back of your net to Jack you up
and then this whole place goes this year
look at me when I'm talking to you what
could be anything you want me to be God
[Music]
got like modern zombies
I feel like yeah
that was various
who's there
I don't think he's dead
oh you
yeah there should have been a little bit
of a fight there
um I don't think he's dead
he was a little bit too badass to be
dead that easy
I think he's still alive
I do want that ability he was using he
was like throwing them yeah I need that
I need that in my life I need some
health that's what I need
I'm struggling
why is
where are we going
aftermath
necessity
what is required
to make the hard choices look for R
Kelly sir
oh my God
I gotta look for the
I gotta look for the uh
the cell that has the PlayStation 5
posters on it the Jim Ryan posters in it
and I gotta find the uh
the cell that got all the ramen noodles
oh
that'll be playing
[Music]
I think that was cool I couldn't see it
they do a good job at like jump scare
tactics where they they make you jump at
something I'll give them that I didn't
expect that I walked in the door and I
got clapped so I'll give them that that
was that was that was pretty good
thank you
necessity
we fight we find uh
we found R Kelly's
uh R Kelly's cell and it's really got
Xboxes in it
he's got a picture of uh a Phil Spencer
that's saying you saved Xbox Brian thank
you Phil
one two
come on so this one's two
oh yeah I only have you once
yeah I hit him twice
let him go let him rock it
hit him twice again
six times
six times it took to kill him it's
really inconsistent like how many hits
it takes
how did these break
how did these break
got a God of War our way through this
obviously
go go go
oh Jacob saved this man shout out to
Jacob
Jacob saved Our Lives
shout out to Jacob man
get a little bit of Health
no we go we we looking around first
Jacob
I'm hurting
doing back there we looking around Jacob
we looting
we need credits we need some
some health we need all kinds of stuff
Jacob
[Music]
look at this jacob follow the left yard
have no health no money shut the hell up
Jacob oh no I'm Jacob I don't know who
he is I am Jacob
take that over to the reforge you can
use it to print a new weapon
ugc printing at your Circa valid choice
I don't I don't have 800 dollars
I don't have air
oh hold up I think this is what he wants
me to do no
Jacob homie give me money
nothing's free in this world even a
zombie apocalypse apparently
have a United day
a valid choice
invalid sure I don't have 800 dollars
I got I got a Buck 22 man that's got to
be worth something
I don't want to sell that either
oh hold up watch him give me some money
here this is gonna be some money
nice
yes the 800 credits you online
yeah print me that man
there we go
if we're gonna get out
of [ __ ] one of you can fly now I found
an inmate with the skills to hack the
network according down from orbit
users are in the shoe maximum security
oh he's in the shoes
yeah ever since I got it voice acting is
pretty good guys what'd you guys think
you think the voice acting is pretty
good
maybe the lipstick you could have could
have been a little bit better but I
think that might be more of the models
than anything
it is and I'll guide you along don't you
leave me hanging okay why can't I go
with you though
why you got it right now I'll get that
door for you why can't I go with you
let me go with you
doing me wrong man
strategic targeting system after
performing combo attack look for the
indicators Target on the enemy press and
hold the left trigger and quickly press
the right trigger to automatically hit
the enemy and fire the weapon to score
an extra hit okay so they they just
saying be quick about it be quick about
it
messy with this PlayStation thing man
I'm sure we'll talk about an IOP
you're gone
eat them oh he looks delicious too
where are you going
[Music]
oh
I didn't I didn't know that was a door
my bad
I didn't know that was a door
I'm finding it like hard to believe that
I couldn't go with that dude I get it he
might have like access codes to get
doors that you wouldn't normally be able
to get to but you cannot just walk right
behind him
how are they gonna know
over here
over here
I ain't going to you
we ain't doing that
I ain't going to you
sticking up on you
come on man
that's cool
I wonder how like realistic it is to
like handle a lot of situations with
with shooting or with that that stab
though
oh God
what is this
oh he ain't he ain't playing
all right so that's cool
all right you know
I'm getting a hand of the the melee
system a little bit but I don't like it
all right let's go up here
okay
foreign
is he gonna break it down or something
's about to happen
I would love to return to myself just
don't hit me I'm on my way
oh there's two of them there
clearly I gotta fight them
I wish the robot would do something
foreign
can he see me here
how is
how is the
okay
yeah he's gonna see me
yeah he's gonna
come on guys
I should have waited
well I got rid of one of their hands
all right so he's gone
[Music]
oh the violence in this game's good
though it really is I gotta give them
that to get
the violence in this game is good
I don't know about the robot stuff
I feel like the robot should have walked
around like big daddies you have to run
from them
Big Daddy's in uh Bioshock I think that
would have been good
this is clearly locked
well there was someone in here
is there like a
probably one of those power
uh I can but I don't think I have a
whole lot of bullets so I don't want to
it's probably strategically better just
to stick with this
and I'm probably shooting
playing on hard now I'm playing on a
basic mode man I don't do the hard stuff
I'm not trying to like give myself an
aneurysm just trying to play a game
especially how spongy these enemies are
already I can't imagine on hard probably
beat them for like 10 minutes before
they die
do some Assassins Creed spongy what is
going on
yeah shut up
maybe there's a vent somewhere
let's look for a vent
I need a vent
of some sort
what's up flame share my uh my stream on
Twitter guys tell them attic is
streaming and someone backseat gaming
did you see something I missed
because I didn't I don't
yeah shut the hell up
wow dead Cars nearby
I mean it's kind of hard to see what all
these people are
oh yeah we killed a guard at the
beginning
but he said nearby though I found one
yeah there we go
he's gonna rip
wait what yeah
what a mess
they're giving a lot more personality to
this individual
some good detail on the character you
see the gun uh behind his belt
they have good good detail like look all
right all right all right let's let's
have a real conversation let's have a
real conversation
let me blow me up a little bit
all right so far let's be real here
the game is underwhelming a lot of
aspects but the one thing I will say we
got to keep in mind we can't compare
this individual Studio to most Studios
it's our first game and as much as we
love to criticize there is a point where
we gotta be fair it's their first game
and to me
this is a pretty good attempt at a first
game to my knowledge it's their first
game it might not be their first game
but to my knowledge this is their first
game and I think so far even though with
the nitpicks and stuff I don't like this
is a good
thing to going into you know your first
attempt at a game I think um
the franchise has potential if if they
don't like
if there's able to make a sequel because
I don't know how the game ends
but we'll continue and I look
Samba I tell you to buy it for 70
because all right let's get serious
Let's Get Serious
this game is 70 and I think that hurts
it they should have came out at like a
50 range
um but
I would tell you to support it just off
off of this even if you don't like it
entirely I feel like we got to start
supporting these smaller developers that
are trying to Branch into these AAA
products more
you know uh because I feel like we need
more people in the AAA space and the
only way we're gonna
surely get that is we got to support the
people that are trying to do it and
doing it at a decent rate
is there problems with this game so far
yes
I like how they tell you're gonna lose
five minutes if you reset checkpoint
that's cool but
I feel like
if we support these developers if they
actually achieve what they were trying
to do and they messed up certain things
I feel like with that support they'll be
able to to do better the next time you
know I feel like every game for the most
part deserves a sequel every game
deserves a sequel because developers
deserve to try to take the concept that
they originally intended and with
feedback make it better but the problem
is if we don't support them at this
level they're not going to be able to
get the opportunity to make it better
if that makes sense to you guys I hope
that makes sense to you guys
and I'm not saying like AAA products
this is not a triple this is I mean AAA
companies this is not a triple a company
but the issue God uh Embrace yours I
feel like
I feel like
if they're bought
that's when the company goes down
because they'll be bought by who they
gonna be bought by the people that won't
give opportunities and innervate the
gaming industry
true but I'll support them when it goes
on sale because this will look like I
get I get that song but I do uh no
problem with that if you want to
support them when they drop to like 50
bucks 40 bucks hell if you want to wait
though 20 10 or Game Pass it's up to you
because I do think there's layers to
buying games
I'm never going to tell you to buy a
game blindly
I'm not gonna do that but I do feel like
for the good of the industry there's
layers to it
can you grab me
oh
I agree there's a lot of Truth what
you're saying there uh Mark I I would
say
man I'm getting tired of them just
randomly showing up places
thank you
come on man
come on
yeah how you was that less arm
how you feel no r
ope yeah score score was a very unique
experience I didn't beat it but I can
understand where you know they could
evolve that brand
come on
but I do feel like this game has a lot
of Polish behind it like a lot of Polish
behind it kudos to them man you know
so
let's go let's get it
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing
I feel like the designs could be a
little bit different ow
foreign
Don you ask a good question there let me
get a little bit farther and we'll talk
about that at the end
because uh you know probably here in
about 30 minutes I'm gonna wrap it up
we're gonna talk about the game
just my first impressions
some health
oh never mind
I don't even care about these recordings
anymore
but let's read it for the chat
stacked in the hall the first case came
in an hour ago
and we have to find more
all right so it's like
someone brought these in I don't think
it was us because I noticed people were
trying to blame us for this
um someone did bring these in I don't
know who it is yet but we'll figure that
out Chad we'll figure that out
we need this though what we need is some
help
give me something for our health
I bet you feel stupid don't you
feel real stupid don't you
watch him breaking that glass
door locks I don't like how some doors
lock and some doors don't I feel like
that's a cop-out
oh
finally I get to pick up someone's
someone's limb and beat someone with it
oh that glove is how that dude did it he
loves the captain pharah's hat
do I like that
clearly they jacked that from Dead Space
to some degree though we got to keep it
real
got a gate fuse
grip
to launch items
all right let's see here
they're gonna have it
come on
[Music]
ow
Ed like he had a bad day
knocked his head off straight off
I guess there is a stage four maybe
that's when the actual people like
take over
how we in the med Bay room and I can't
find nothing to heal myself with
they didn't know what was going on
oh use the grip
how do I use it
what's up
what you doing
oh
ah
maybe I should have took him a little
bit more serious
I definitely got took out I got hit
pretty hard
um
we'll get to here in a minute uh ASAP
gaming
um
here in a minute I'm a
I'm a probably boot up a different game
but we'll talk about this game first
Oh
How You Like Me Now now that I'm on my
way
I don't need that okay maybe I need that
gun
thank you
oh there's another one oh he's a big boy
too
you a big dude
yeah I'm shooting that one
oh
hey
now you got no arm
oh
yeah that was
that was something
that was something
I couldn't really have the opportunity
to use the grip that dude was on me man
it's gonna be someone around this corner
man
uh I don't have Need for Speed out uh
found
how you like it though I'm not really a
big fan of Need for Speed anymore
I like the I like the chase in the car
uh getting chased by the cops ass but
I don't think uh however not like that
printing At Your Service oh got a glove
looks like they got a little bit of a
error error of course it's era
10 free hours for Game Pass
that's cool
uh I got
ah
thank you
grip batteries the grip will slowly
recharge over time and can also be
recharged quickly with the grip battery
if the grip runs out of power while
holding an enemy or object it will drop
the grip will automatically consume a
battery from the inventory if available
to refill the blue grip power of meteor
on the on the back of Jacob's neck grip
batteries can also be used manly in the
inventory screen grip batteries can be
picked up
found found inside loot crates and drop
by enemies
so we got a little lfg going on here RNG
I mean
we got another grip battery
operating room
so I don't think they're going to use
the grip by the grip device for a lot of
puzzles because it will like consume
that like they do on Dead Space I don't
think they're going to do that
oh what is this
okay
there's some form of listen
ing
some form
of intelligence with these people
they're gonna string them up like this
no he's talking about Need for Speed
uh when we were talking about that
gonna rip that out of his neck
never gets dull I've noticed
all right let's look around
foreign
how does this dude know so much about
the prison I understand that he's a
prisoner but how do you know how to
operate some of these things in the
prison
wow
ironically there's something you can do
it with
I feel like the the the weight of the
elevator wouldn't be stopped so easily
yeah
fairly
maybe he stopped it just enough not to
die from the impact
oh oh
what is this what is this
let's light it is let's try to eat it oh
never mind
what the hell
I ain't gonna even say what that thing
was
what is going on over there
let's take
you know oh
oh
ow
I'm not wasting ammo on this one
man
I'm getting messed up
cut it cut it cut it
why does it go back in like that and
then die
it's kind of convenient
I'm gonna need more than antibiotics I'm
gonna need a priest
all kinds of stuff
oh it's like the same animations when he
hits you that just one arm fall off I
think it's the arm that you try to hit
him with I think that's the arm that
keeps falling off
I'm waiting for him this time
come on I know where you're coming I
know where you're coming
yeah
oh you still got me
I feel like that's unnecessary
it's unnecessary a little bit
another one of those things
thank you
yeah we ain't dealing with that
wasn't another one of those things right
here
oh my God
get off of me
foreign
come on man hit me twice I feel more
comfortable when you hit me twice
because now I can get three hits off
your ass
okay maybe just two
[Music]
oh
that was kind of scary
foreign
let's get this out
because we know where he's coming from
I don't like Cali gets
all right just two it's the most
consistent hit
available
there's a lot of set pieces in the
beginning I'll agree with you on that
a little bit of false advertising at the
beginning
just a little bit
yeah I'm at a health uh shots
I'm starting to learn the melee system
foreign
who's taking credits during an
apocalypse
these things come out of nowhere
combat could definitely be better
I feel like you got to stop this somehow
I'm not getting close to it we've seen
what happens when you get close to these
things
hold on let me see if I can grab this
Blood
let's get this out
come on
oh look at that they try to trip me out
one step two step three step four
there you go
work hazard
I'm scared to go near this thing
all right so we need to find a
a
one of those fuses
they got to be here somewhere
maybe it's on the top level
I need a fuse
it's got to be a fuse here somewhere
how do I get in there
all right so that doesn't open
oh
what's going on here
playing on a normal difficulty doctor
that's why I want to I don't like
playing on those hard difficulties
because I feel like all they do is just
make them more Buffy and like most uh
I'm not about in order to make
difficulty you just make people more
squishy and I felt like that's all they
do they just make sponges when they make
difficult challenges what is that
oh there's three of them
can I take one out before I have to
fight the other two
oh I shouldn't have jumped down
come on
yeah I'm definitely getting seen
oh I'm definitely getting seen
oh let me get this one just let me get
him let me get him
didn't make no sense
[Music]
got a bigger dude
the other two are gonna gonna join in
[Music]
that was like
I don't know
I don't know
you know what
come on man
come on all of you get up here get oh
you shooting stuff at me come on guys
come on guys
let's go let's go you and me all of you
versus me you're probably gonna win but
man I'm gonna try I'm a try
three versus two this isn't fair four
versus two I don't know what this thing
is
but we go ahead
and I lost
I lost
I lost I didn't I didn't even know the
dude left of me man
I ain't know what was going on I'll be
real with the chat
I didn't know what was going on
let's find that dude that came at me
like that he's got to be here somewhere
he just snuck up on me
come on
yeah let's shoot you
guys can be hesless
armless
I ain't playing
oh my God man
why is there two of those big dudes and
and I feel like you can't shove them
foreign like where does that dude come
from
hey are you not going down there with
your buddy okay
I need you separated
I probably shouldn't have shot you but
it's okay man we're moving past us
oh my God
foreign
here here's the thing
you don't get a lot of options with
stealth you guys saw I tried to stealth
the original Dude it wouldn't let me
just want me to stealth the little guys
but the problem is they're spawning
people behind me that's not on the map
that's an issue I don't like that
all right let's just come on man I'll
fight you two be me and you
or you your little friend over here
we'll fight each other
because we got he's here somewhere
come on man
yeah
let's go let's go
I'm gonna fight YouTube
separate you
foreign
yeah the camera angles a little bit
annoying
I didn't even know he was using that on
me all right we're done with cholesterol
protocol okay guys we're done with
cholesterol protocol uh we're going to
talk about it we're gonna talk about it
let's talk about cholesterol protocol
I'm still probably gonna beat it
I don't know yet
I don't know I don't know how I feel
about it yet
so let's
I'm gonna load up the next game that
we're gonna play
which is uh midnight Suns feel like we
give like two hours each we'll play
we'll do that but let's talk about let's
walk up at this game first and then
we'll
go into
this
let's turn this down all the way
I don't need to hear it on my screen
either all right so
let let's talk man how do you guys feel
about cholesterol protocol
let me stop it from recording
tea time with the attic I'm not I'm not
French or or British
or whatever it is okay
how you guys feel about it give me a
little bit of uh
how you guys feel about it
I was hoping lower Cognito would be here
to discuss his Mets losing their ace
pitcher and free agency
it's cool
all right get some uh some questions
here okay I'm not sure I'm hearing not
so good reviews about it I do think okay
hear me out I do think some of the
reviews aren't Fair because I was
reading a couple of them and it seemed
like
they cared more about it not being dead
space than not its own issues and I have
I do have an issue with that because I
do feel like it's not fair to compare
the two like that
so yeah I do think it's not fair to
compare the two like that
yeah okay so
I did see someone talk about earlier
what I should compare the game when it
comes to like the melee portion
I do feel like the melee portion of
callistral protocol
uh let me you know what I got you guys
hold up
screen capture
because I did record
some
some gameplay when I was
playing
let me see here
all right here's the gameplay
I gotta put it down
still bigger than normal
but uh so
when it comes to this game
actually let's put
let's put the gameplay side to side
with me
how does that look chat do you like that
scanning for active core signatures
stuff going on right now
uh do you guys care if it's on a little
bit just like a little bit not much I
did turn it down almost where you
couldn't hear it but it will be in the
background in some way shape or form
how does this look to you guys do you
guys like this
it's the gameplay I took when I was
recording it
all right so
I do believe
that the lack of shooting mechanics in
this game
is the biggest contributor to why this
game is getting the reviews that it's
getting I
can't hear me
is it that loud
I haven't like really down
is it is it really that loud guys
all right um I turned it down a little
bit more but I feel like
this game
if they would have made it to where you
had the
the same type of ammo restraints
I feel like that you had like Resident
Evil Dead Space
and they really focused you to to really
use the melee portion of the game they
really wanted you to focus on using that
and then but you there is aspects that
you could use with the shooting I feel
like the shooting is an extension of the
melee and it should be both of them have
their own unique playing Styles but they
encourage you to use them both but it
feels like the shooting is just an
extension of the melee and I don't think
I don't think that is what they should
have done they should have had it to
where look if you want to shoot people
we got that kind of gameplay for you if
you want to to do a stealth type of
thing we got that type of gameplay for
you maybe put some RPG trees in here
I do think this is a great Foundation I
do think this is a good foundation and I
think they should be proud of what they
did here so far I've only played like
two hours of it uh but I do understand
there's issues that people are having
with the game I do understand that and I
see I see
they should have done more I do see that
they should have really tried to see how
people are going to react to the melee
thing it's kind of like
yeah
it's kind of like the remember when
bleeding edge came out
it's kind of like that where people
they don't they're not feeling bleeding
edge because it was just melee sometimes
you had to have both to achieve
something
and I think that's the biggest issue of
this game is that it doesn't feel like
there's both it feels like for the most
part they encourage you to
to really do the melee thing and I think
people just want to have the option to
play the game the way they want to play
it
and I think if they would have actually
you know really
I
part of me feels like they did what they
did
because they want to be unique too they
because let's be real here if they would
have just came out and they would have
just had
a style like like Dead Space
we would be saying that they copied them
you guys know we would we'd say oh it's
just a it's just a dead space clone
I don't I think a lot of the issues with
cholesterol protocol could actually be
fixed by just minor minor patches you
know maybe try to rebalance the gun in
the game
you know maybe try to rebalance how much
damage the ads can take in the game
because I feel like
you're not getting enough time to
actually lack how you want to do stuff I
think for the most part you're just
going around hitting people with a baton
and I think that's the issue people
aren't getting enough variety and and
a variety of gameplay
all they're getting is pretty much the
game wants you to play the way the game
wants you to play and it's not really
want you to do anything different I
think the most gameplay would have made
the combat better
yeah see the way I see it is like a
Walking Dead
you know you're probably better off in
most scenarios trying to sneak around
and taking one off uh taking out one by
one to get to a better scenario and I
think that we can all agree on that that
for the most part in the survive in an
environment like this
you're going to want to take one at a
time out so they don't swarm you but I
think
the problem is that that's the only
gameplay they really gave like think
about like I said The Walking Dead for
the most part they only really take
swords
axes anything with sharp objects and
that's how they deal with the walkers
but when things get real they pull out
those AKs they pull out those M16s like
they shoot people
and I think they're not giving you the
option to like really build anything now
there was a store in the game and I'm
thinking maybe that could change a
little bit of the way the game plays
I'm thinking maybe that could that could
fix some stuff but as far as that right
now it's just like
they gotta do something man they I think
hold up my girls texted me
huh
I think that a lot of the issues that I
personally have so far with the game
could be handled just
could be handled just by doing some
patches
that's my personal opinion
how do you guys feel though I mean you
guys saw me play it for a little bit how
do you guys feel
I'm sitting my girl
all of those
pictures that the app did oh it only let
me pick a certain amount
how do you guys feel about it
uh graphically looks dope but so far
gameplay is lacking I think that's
that's a big issue is the gameplay I
think the graphics are pretty good I
would like a little bit more attention
to detail in certain aspects but I'm not
gonna like really ride it too much on
that
apparently right Trace is not working
properly on Xbox uh fine on PlayStation
gameplay looks like Kingdom Eva I'd
agree like I said I think that's a fair
analysis the game needed a lot more
ingredients yeah it is I think they do
certain things decent but I don't think
they uh you know the things that matter
like the melee in order to do a
full-blown melee game there needs to be
more gameplay mechanics to the melee
than just dodging hitting and I think
you know maybe they could have I feel
like a lock-on system where you can
actually aim for certain aspects of the
of their of their limbs like take out
their feet first maybe that would have
been a little bit better but there's
nothing like that like when you play
Dead Space you add a variety of
different ways you can achieve the same
scenario with shooting you could shoot
uh you know horizontally vertical you
know if you use the Plasma Pistol or the
the laser cut or whatever it's called
you could take out their limbs before
they get close to you and I think that's
what made Dead Space special was the
aspect that you were always
go You Were Always On The Edge that
anything at any time it could get really
bad for you and you had to shoot
strategically and I think that is what
made Dead Space special and I feel like
they could have did that here
you know
have a system where you can hit down or
up and you could take out limbs first
but you know they didn't Implement
anything I don't know if they can apply
anything like to that into the game but
I'm very curious what they do because
clearly the performance on PC needs to
be handled the issues they're having on
uh Xbox needs to be handled but I do
really would like for them to go and do
some balancing updates and I feel like
this game would get received a lot
better with some minor balancing updates
with like the gun you know you you
balance that you also balance the you
know how much damage the uh the enemies
could take I feel like that's a big
issue as well
foreign
I heard that there's an orange fog or
something fighting on PC I don't know I
haven't played on PC
I don't really play too much stuff on PC
but I'm kind of curious I'm curious with
you guys man I'm curious with you guys
you know let's delete this we don't need
this anymore
all right so here's uh Marvel Sons
I'm gonna play on normal
I can't hear oh yeah I gotta turn it up
all right so let me share this link out
to Twitter
because I've I've started Marvel
all right let me
let me tweet I'm really curious on this
game
curious how this game's gonna do
I guess Marvel
what is this game called
midnight Suns
all right so let me go ahead and
repost the link
all right now let me
I'm going to do a time stamp for this
guys
two hours and we'll say 15 minutes from
uh for when Marvel starts because I feel
like that's fair if people want to see a
certain game
why isn't
you know I'm just gonna type I don't
care
time stamp
this is ridiculous
let's just delete that
sometimes streaming is so annoying
time stamps on stream
um
almost done guys
all right so the game
make sure I spell these right
c-a-l-i-s-t-o
protocol
starts I'm gonna think it's like three
minutes in because I didn't do the um
the starting soon screen very long
so I think it was three minutes and then
what we said the Marvel midnight
Sons started at one hour
and 15 minutes we'll say that
now we're good
let me go back to the chat
all right coming to Game Pass apparently
um so McCain I don't know what summer
King said
I I wonder if sons does come to Game
Pass anytime soon
foreign
oh
I love Marvel
I don't know why I do love Marvel
they revive in someone
foreign
Marvel
midnight Sons
six months later
Carl told me he liked it so far
Cog was playing it last night I wanted
to to save it for the Stream
Johnny Blaze Ghost Rider I'm pretty sure
that's Ghost Rider yeah
Iron Man Doctor Strange
original Ghost Rider I thought there was
a ghost writer before Johnny Blaze
I think
I think Johnny plays tripping I I he
can't take those two
it's Iron Man
too
I don't even know the midnight suns are
I think King needs to explain that to me
foreign
the graphics look a little underwhelming
I'm gonna be real with you
they look a little underwhelming
why isn't there any it doesn't sound
like is there sound of the game stream
guys
yeah they look pretty bad I'm gonna be
real with you hold up
oh my god with this audio thing
they must have did some update on um
must have did some update on
on the OBS sound
is it going to turn back on
oh there it goes
did it freeze
I think it froze
uh
let me just redo it
sometimes they'd be messing up I don't
know why
all right
all right there we go
you like minus is probably freezing
right now
um I'm
all right can you guys hear it now
can you guys hear it now
you should be able to hear it now
all right tell me if it's a good um
mixture for you guys too so you got
regular attack
cards
air superiority okay let's
so can you just keep shooting over and
over again
impressive
am I really gonna have to bring out the
big guns for this
that'll work
is it better now I turned it up a little
bit
I defeated all the enemies
okay so now in my turn
thank you
I like it when we're in control of the
situation yeah it's turn base
there are two different types of enemies
minions and Elites minions have no
Health uh minions have no Health any
damage defeats them instantly they are
frail but still dangerous at least a
fire out total and require more damage
to defeat use the tax and enroll cards
wisely all right so pretty much saying
don't
don't use big cards
for the minions
all right so
so that okay I wonder if that'll kill
him in the background though
all right so okay okay
foreign
yeah I think I have the legendary
edition I can't remember
[Music]
so it's got like an AOE effect
ow
how angry you've made my clothes
shall we get on with it at the start of
each turn because we'll appear above
each image
okay so it shows me who they're gonna
attack
so it looks like they're all going to
attack talk to Strange
all right don't mention it
got to do the knockbacks to do is a
little bit more damage
give 20 block to an ally
all right so he's gonna hit him so I'm
gonna buff him up
I appreciate it I already played
Callisto uh wavy so you after the part
stream or if you want to watch that you
can go ahead and go back to the street
uh back a little bit on the string
foreign
well they really hitting me
I like our chances
all right so ACP already hits everyone
on a certain part of the mat
Rix of Titan
you can't make it happen in the next 10
seconds I'm not interested
um
I got a lot of a lot of thought process
behind
cholesto I I do think maybe a little bit
it's being unfairly criticized just a
little bit I don't think it's like
everyone's wrong in the way they feel
but I feel like they're comparing it too
much to Dead Space
that is my opinion on the matter I think
that
you know people want dead space that
remake so bad I think that they are
acting like
that game can't get
that it's got to be more like dead space
than its own thing
all right so you can't throw a rock
this should be good
yeah I'm not gonna lie I'm kind of
filling the tutorial
man I already stopped that once
they're not quite ready to give up
I'm feeling good about the situation or
things considered
oh I think that's the last of them which
is good I might have told pepper I was
just stepping outside the restaurant to
take a quick call
I'm still single
you can get a lot of uh people on your
team apparently
thank you
it I think the game could look better
but as far as like play I like it so far
I like the animations they look clean
these trailers this ain't it though
this this should have been
looking a little bit sharper I'm gonna
be real
the collective works of the universe's
greatest Sorcerers and he left them
underneath the takeout menus
shifting mystical polarities are
wreaking havoc on my points if you don't
say you okay kid
Scarlet Witch
yes are you let's uh put a pin in that
Miss Marvel
our Mightiest Hero really freaking
powerful
really showed up by homeowners insurance
what is going on
the wards of protection if you please
fight I've got control now then show me
by activating the wards in the meantime
in honor of our missing companion the
rest of you may feel free to
[Music]
mother
ready when you are boss
nice one Carol always the direct
approach you know I don't mess around
besides we picked up some crazy gamma
reads coming from well here guessing
that explains the hydro goons and
ominous green lights
all right
let's do this guys let's do this
so we got Miss Marvel with this
um
I think this win thing would be good
I wish you could rotate how he does it
fair enough
um
so these are more important characters
how many people
let's go after this dude
foreign
redraw
yeah let's redraw that
so you have a certain amount of
redrawals you can do every
all right she's got a regular Jab
I like this is kale
foreign
all right there we go
moving Heroes
yes I need a move
wealth and power
the king of fascism
pick up this chair and hit him
up to five okay
draw two cards
draw the last two attack played start
the turn with four cards
we can do a knock back
so we'll knock him back to him
attention
she doesn't care about you and I hope
you realize that in time
Lilith
is that all of them
uh reinforcements okay
all right let's do this
double your current heroism
so that's pretty much to do bigger
attacks you need to do that
these are ability cards okay
and these aren't regular ads and so you
have to actually do damage to them
can I move here
this co-op in this game
is there co-op in this game
I didn't know there's golf in the game
got to do a lot of
strategic stuff in this game I see
I hope this is one of the stronger arms
oh yeah I see I did this before
that's got an AOE attack I probably
could have hit them both
Awards something's blocking them
foreign
mother of demons harbinger of the
Midnight Sun prophecy or not you
overstep challenging the sorcerer
Supreme we're about to get destroyed
yep
we need we need the Scarlet Witch to
mess with this chick
you just drained her power no
no
you remind me of my own beloved
all right that's interesting
[Laughter]
the prophecy is in motion Lilith is
still out there growing stronger each
second the Midnight Sun approaches
defines stronger if we are to have any
chance of stopping her there is only one
option left to us
I won't go
we all must eventually face our demons
Miss maximoff
however
one of us should remain behind to
maintain the wards of protection
see you on the other side
okay he did that one on purpose the
fabric of magic is unwinding we are
fortunate so far so good I've actually
really enjoying this game but I like
these type of games so you can't really
take my opinion on the matter too much
oh suburbs nice
Welcome to The Abbey
home of the Midnight Sun
oh blade
Lewis Jr demon League wait it's that
jerk from TVs which one
now is everyone would just take a moment
caretaker
you're standing on my flowers oh in a
long time Sarah it's caretaker now if I
could have avoided this moment I would
but oh spare me the speech I know Lila's
back
we are sisters after all
oh
shall we chat
this is interesting
it's always make everything sound so
lofty
I raised my sister's only child as a
weapon against her
and saved the world in the process now
you want me to dig them up and ask them
to do it again
I did not write the prophecy Sarah
besides I am no common grave Robert
their Corporal form
speaking of what help to have a mental
image for the procedure spare no detail
spiritual identity theft is no laughing
matter
[Music]
all right choose your body type
um
um doesn't seem like there's a lot of
let's randomize
can you random likes that whole thing no
a lot of randomization
okay
I guess
is that who they're Reviving is you
came the night
oh what's going on
foreign
got magic
I bet you blades over there like man I
wish I could do some magic
fish
as far as Resurrection
I see worse
particularly on myself hmm
come on it's perfectly safe that thing
wakes up and takes a bite out of you
don't blame him or so are you a vampire
s nowhere else I should be just saw that
star guy looking around but I irritated
find me as soon as they awaken and blade
be nice
you know play got to be on the team man
play gotta be on the team
part one Awakening
it's so cold
but the air burns with every breath
has it been so long
are you a vampire or what
I'm curious what you are
in my dreams it was always I look like
girls a little bit man
I'm a witch hunter
sense
I am not alone
I have to admit Hunter you make one hell
of an entrance
blade
I can't wait to see the new blade
guess that makes two of us don't you
don't you like her they kind of made him
look a little bit like Wesley Snipes To
Me Maybe it's to me regret your error
and caretaker told me to be nice
relax Slayer I'm a friend you just don't
know it yet yes I saw you with Sarah
before
but what would she want with a Vampire
unless
the name's blade and I'm No Ordinary
vampire
I get you've been out of commission but
I thought you noticed since we're having
this little Showdown under the freaking
Sun the temperature
day Walkers were a myth even to me
says to half human half demon Monster
Hunter
oh you can
you're right I do hunt technology and
last I checked vampires are monsters
you want to take a run at me you can try
it but I got my name for a reason
I've probably killed more vampires than
you've ever seen hero
such fighting spirit
no wonder caretaker chose you
right as much as I'd love to see how
much weirder this comes it's just the
90s flaps
look but the 90s were a nice time man
the 90s were a nice time we have wasted
too much time here already
man the others are really gonna love you
others
yeah you've got a little fan club I
think but why spoil the surprise
hope you're up for the challenge Chosen
One
foreign
man this looks
I'm be real with you guys
I'm b-rolled you guys
the this
these Graphics ain't it
these Graphics ain't that
did I
Hunter
not sure if you remember me but we met
briefly before I'm the witch who called
me back from the grave
I told you
or Nico but neither works and this is
Robbie Reyes
oh man never thought I'd be standing
next to you got quite a rip I mean
caretakers told us stories
that's Ileana brilliant and I think you
already met played
course
caretaker has reformed the midnight Suns
whoa how did you your power I can feel
it I always do
so welcome home I guess we I never left
right
well we can fast forward through the
tour then
interesting yeah is still well you know
yeah the basic stuff dorms War Room
Library a few places assume this is the
Hub world
I have to say for a Honda transient
Castle raised on the cursed grounds of
Old Salem it's pretty cozy
that doesn't stop
we can all thank Robbie for the Wi-Fi
the Wi-Fi
oh and one more thing we've got some new
house guests now you think we're a Fun
Bunch just wait until you meet that by
playing the series
we're here
yeah I'm waiting for the update too
long Bruce now
there is
prophecies be damned it's good to see
that yes I will be reviewing Fire Emblem
engines
probably a lot older
how long was I in that Crypt Sarah
no more than a few centuries you were
missed centuries
and what of Lilith Fallen by your hand
until now
ah yeah so speaking of Lilith Tony what
the kids literally speaking of Lilith
Tony that's my name
Tony that's uh Carol and Dr spooky over
there here to help
help with what exactly oh I don't know
throwing the magic amulet into the
volcano smiting the dragon mother you
tell us kid you are the chosen one after
all I like Iron Man do you recall
of that last encounter child
there was
a
voice
the rest is hazy
oh a voice that's it a voice that's what
we have to go on results of your long
Crypt sleep most likely
a minor inconvenience everything
required to restore those memories is
contained within my sanctum I will
simply alert Wanda to prepare the
necessary rituals
[Music]
what
straight to voicemail some sorcer
Supreme
mystical interference caused by this
little pocket dimension of yours perhaps
Agatha can help
allow me
[Music]
alato
oh she got magic too
bound to Enchanted Babylonian Soul glass
we just call it the mirror table
impossible nothing on Earth could
possibly affect those Wars Wanda's in
trouble Wanda is troubled
I'll go
you'll need my help of course then let
us make haste Dr spooky Dr spooky
[Music]
crazy day huh
crazy indeed
lots of new blood around here
seriously powerful headliners
powerful yes
with everything going on right now we
simply cannot afford to lose contact
all right so this is what we're gonna do
we're probably gonna play
One mission
with that tutorial and then you know
it's probably a wrap you guys I've been
streaming for almost three hours
unless Bruce is right about Gamma
interference
if such a thing could even exist
Wards have been activated before and
I've never experienced such a reaction
or are you gonna let me talk to you you
raced that timeline so as not to affect
my own death
you can just erase timelines when when
did he get that ability
I like throwing when he got that ability
to start a race the timelines
your translucency spell must be failing
all right then I guess I'm going to move
forward
it won't let me speak to him
[Music]
I think Dragon Age Inquisition might
look better than this game is that sad
is that sad guys
Lilith possesses the dark hold if she
forced her way into my sanctum sanctorum
once I suspect she can do it again you
are a sorcerer of supreme can you not
predict her movements
normally yes
but since your mother breached the
sanctum my sense of the future has grown
volutinous in nature
is that another language or
fuzzy my predictions are fuzzy
for the first time a sorcerer's Supreme
I cannot foresee how the future unfolds
and with my Apprentice in danger we
cannot Tarry
don't worry doctor
we'll save your home your sanctum Will
Survive we shall see to that
don't worry doctor
we got this
I do not doubt Wanda
he got the ability off screen
all right so
got a little bit of friendship stuff
about
time not I like blade about time Mr
Brook's time space reality the building
blocks of magic
all must be constant for my portals to
work properly
oh
no
that is no longer the case we've heard
several times otherwise I would still be
hunting dread maidens in my sleep indeed
and while I certainly appreciate the
view of this Vista
see how it will hasten our return to the
sanctum magic is the answer no as I've
just stated magic is the problem your
magic is
not ours
the ground you are standing on you guys
are stupid on Twitter man a mystical
Anchor Point to ileana's realm that I
get you I get you
you are standing in limbo
Nexus of all realities both real or
otherwise
a chaotic but secret Realm what is going
on
I get it there's a lot of stuff going on
YouTube when using an ability in combat
agrees
defeat All Enemies to complete the
encounter I hesitate to call this Good
seeing minimal Hydro resistance quick
slash
looks can be deceiving I'm afraid
there's no way to
wait here it goes Blaze
oh I like it I like it
restore 30 health
attack with the QR code from the clip oh
so you can use
quick
forceful knockback
so I got a whip
throw that whip
got it in my turn
man they really don't feel strange
[Music]
that hurt a bit
all right let's do this again
knock back
the game plays good but I could tell a
lot of people ain't gonna like the way
this game looks
herself could not fast me what makes you
think you will Fair any further
hail that
all right so
all right
Hunter out level two
they're just shooting blade like Ain't
No Tomorrow
quick Knock back so this
watch and learn my friend all right
let's go
I wonder if you could pick up those
items
yeah you can't
you can't here's some paper
get educational my friend
it's gonna be a global 15 for that or
something
can we hit him twice yeah we can
I already played it my friend played it
for about two two hours
go back in the Stream it starts about
three minutes
never seen that before
impressive
fight interesting I like the combat I do
think the combat's unique
he's guided as they are remember Hydra
is still human under
not Lillian
you were saying the lifeblood of the
mother pumps through our veins the
mother is eternal Hydra is
what is this
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on
[Music]
oh
the neighborhood association is not
going to like this
no I'll handle it yeah
this is definitely one of those games
you have to enjoy the type of gameplay
is that Venom
Fallen Venom
we are Venom and you are lunch oh that's
cool
[Music]
I guess it's the first boss
foreign
do not forecast which Heroes they tend
to attack it may attack multiple times
on their term watch out quickly do I
even want to know what that Beast is it
calls itself Venom until now
[Music]
I got really bad cards
um let's
[Music]
Doctor Strange
I need you to move right here
fascism
Hydra will never change all right
let's do a knockback
I had a knockback
no it's my main character that in
knockback okay
[Music]
all right so I can't do nothing with him
well that's gonna be right it's gonna be
weird
it seems I'm indisposed at the moment
yo he threw me straight into a barrel
this is not how the
this house belongs to mother
and you belong to us we just
the entrance all right he's got 133.
thankfully no
all right we need a quick attack
to free
it's Doctor Strange
yeah I'm getting I'm getting messed up
right now
[Music]
oh melee ties against falling them can
trigger his joint us Pacific
active Fallen Venom will blind the next
hero that immediately attacks him
use range or to resist okay so I have to
use a range attack
this is gonna hurt I'm not gonna even
hit him
[Music]
ties up with these jumps
all right here we go here we go
who is Venom attacking
oh he ko'd me
will make you feel regret
we may not be ready for this thing yet
might be smarter to pull back until we
know what we're up against here
enemy attacks will go off at the end of
the turn use move or abilities to make
sure
all right all right all right
we gotta get rid of those
not bad not great but not bad
just what I needed
let me show you
this battle requires
first you die
man
mother blesses us with strength
was a vegetarian
all right we gotta focus on him now
forever
range move
look how fragile you are
No Escape
oh man he's doing some damage
um
I don't I don't want to repeat myself
childish I go to the beginning of the
podcast or uh you know I'll definitely
be talking about an IOP too
thank you
praise shall be all
owed
I don't need that
[Music]
[Music]
but after I play Callisto just look for
the screen to be different like right
now what you want to look for is the
screen to be me in the middle and
gameplay to be on the left that's when I
like really break down up closer
protocol after I played it
foreign
awake
oh I'm stunned
let's go twice it's not fair
we'll have to deal with a few more I'm
afraid
I prefer if I didn't have to make
physical contact with the creature
this is a silk shirt all right so I need
knockback
preparation
should really stay down
[Music]
do a little bit of damage to him
he'll get that little
skin thing but I'm not worried about it
at this point
foreign
the resident
there we go
I think we could take him out before he
does it
yeah see believed
foreign
[Music]
oh Spiderman
yo we got Spider-Man on Xbox we got
Spider-Man on Xbox
[Applause]
[Music]
and friendly
Eddie what happened to you that's part
of a horrifyingly terrible New Look the
tongue was gross enough
someone is extra touchy today
always nice to see you too buddy so I'm
thinking your friends here could use a
little break how about I take Eddie here
for his afternoon walk
every duck that's just his way of say he
care
[Music]
that was cool I like that that was a
cool boss
well they give you like these little
comic book group things
it's kind of crazy there's that some
form of uh loading screens in this game
foreign
congratulations
new world or not some things remain
unchanged
the look what look
boldly charging head first into the jaws
of your enemy
courageously risking the lives of
yourself and your teammates
just to play the hero
this is the fire dragon all over again
fire Dragoon my memories may be
fragmented but as I recall
I killed the bastard I lost was a
village I like the banter the banter is
pretty cool
it's why I sent you to help
if Spider-Man hadn't come along today we
could have lost far more than the
sanctum or Wanda she means I could have
died
again putting an end to her Eternal
Crusade against my mother
you've been through a lot
for now it's enough that you all made it
back in one piece
more or less
we'll talk more later
get some rest oh
all right guys
everything got auto save in it these
days terrific
I appreciate everyone coming through man
I almost stream for four hours three
hours and 30 minutes almost I need to
get something to eat call the girlfriend
see how things going with her she's
she's off work by now I'm pretty sure if
we're coming through Matt it was a nice
little stream
um try to give you guys more of these
I've been sick I've got to get the
Pokemon review out to you guys and I
also got to start posting on my actual
YouTube channel definitely go over there
and follow me on YouTube gaming addict
and until next time see you Sunday
well